رعب في وضح النهار
صاروخ روسي يضرب مبنى سكنيًا
في زاباريسيا بأوكرانيا
بعيدًا عن خط المواجهة،
تحطمت الحياة في لحظة
كنت في العمل وكان طفلي وحيدًا في
المنزل تقول سفيتلانا إنها عاشت في
الطابق السادس مع ابنها
إنه يعرف كيف  للمشي في الردهة
أثناء غارة جوية، تقول إنها ربما
أنقذت حياته،
وهذا ما حدث للتو لمنزلي،
تقول هذا الرجل، انظر هذا هو المكان الذي كنت
أجلس فيه مع أمي الآن
ولكن حتى في أعقاب ذلك، لم يكن الخوف
بعيدًا أبدًا  في أوكرانيا،
قال مسؤولون أوكرانيون إن القوات الروسية
أطلقت ستة صواريخ على الأقل على هذه المدينة يوم
الأربعاء، وسارعت فرق البحث والإنقاذ
للعثور على أشخاص محاصرين تحت
الأنقاض، وأطفال صغار بين
المصابين، ووصفها الرئيس زيلينسكي بأنها
وحشية من دولة إرهابية، وبين عشية
وضحاها سرب من طائرات تاهيت بدون طيار.
أطلقت صفارات الإنذار عبر مفاتيح
الدفاع الجوي وأسقطت بعض الطائرات، لكن
سبعة على الأقل قتلوا بالقرب من العاصمة،
وتقول السلطات إن
روسيا نفت مراراً وتكراراً
استهدافها للمدنيين
يوم الأربعاء. سافر الرئيس زيلينسكي
بالقرب من الخطوط الأمامية في
الشرق لزيارة الجنود المصابين وحشد
قواته.  وذكرهم بما
كانوا يقاتلون من أجله،
إنها مهمتكم التاريخية لحماية
أرضنا وإعادة كل ما يخص
أوكرانيا لأطفالنا قال لهم
[موسيقى]